I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
first acting gig at the Elliot Regis
Park to meet you Simon so much for me to
kill a mockingbird eight-mile are you on
my fresh kiddie reverse your first move
my first yeah eight miles no first the
CD album you own Michael Jackson's bad
and now 24 Eminem 8 mama thing first CD
album uh maybe Pulp Fiction soundtrack
buster oh great growls at the release
party for that true story - pop -
pocalypse now my first season's first
nickname sick note cucumber patch sick
note yeah cuz I was get when I was doing
Billy I got to sing a lot nickname I
think sea bass probably I got my with
dog bite yeah pull their first come on
closer
silver mini first car didn't have a 1992
Ford contour contour 2006 black on black
all black 5:45 first IMAX movie probably
start wrecking stones
Titanic really no I think I saw I can't
remember I know I saw the Batman Black
Panther
hey you don't get out much
[Music]
[Music]